la démolition a commencé quinze ans
après la fermeture du site tpc thompson
passif component deux soeurs fin février
il ne devrait plus rien rester de ce
vestige industriel devenu au fil du
temps un abri-bus squatteurs et amateurs
de paintball dans le quartier les
habitants sont soulagés
ça sera pas un mal que ça soit démonté
parce que c'était vraiment un mauvais
paysage même pour les enfants et tous
ont c'était comme à risque il ya eu pas
mal de refus de dents et voilà c'était
pas sécurisant le site est aujourd'hui
méconnaissable
mais en 2002 tpc été le plus gros
employeur de seurre 250 personnes
fabrique est ici des condensateurs et
des composants électroniques
malgré leurs mobilisations successives
notamment en 1996 contre le rachat de
thomson par des où les salariés n'ont
pas pu empêcher la fermeture
marie france avait 57 en 2002 elle n'a
pas fait partie des 149 salariés
reclassés à tpc saint-apollinaire
quinze ans après son dernier piquet de
grève elle a accepté de revenir sur les
lieux
j'ai travaillé longtemps que j'ai
commencé à mon 65 à leur égard à genlis
et puis du fait qu'on a acheté la maison
qui fait muter ici en 72 voilà jusqu'à
la fermeture
c'était vraiment bien une bonne entame
on était une bonne équipe
la municipalité et l'entreprise nova
soeur travaillait à la reconversion de
ce terrain de 23 mille mètres carrés
situé à deux pas du centre ville
cette partie là est maintenant faite
pour de la construction pour de
l'habitat éventuellement des petits
services donc il faudra effectivement
travailler en concertation avec la
propriétaire pour savoir quel avenir on
va donner à ce site
ce nouveau quartier résidentiel ne
sortira pas de terre avant plusieurs
années